gravando acho que sim mas vamos treinar
bem
ramon não se expande em vencer enfim o
pólis e homem onde em não se pode não
ficar mole ninguém só entre ganso e ai
ai vocês já não podes ficando em liga
americana e aí como é que vocês estão
galera do encontro de fãs que a gente
fez pra como é que faz a ajudar uma
criança que a gente faz é pegar uns ovos
gente vai pra onde passa e vai pegar as
criancinhas aí deus vai falar assim o
windows se entregou às criancinhas
mas no futebol é assim eu queria
agradecer a todos os fãs que
compareceram eu queria pedir desculpa
por sotero usar um dia antes desculpa
não poderia ter passado uma semana o
senhor mas seu coração semana forma que
tem contra ele eu acho que colocar
demais e ampla no hotel segurança não
tem essa coisa aí amoled de entrada de
número 6 do brasil são por lo
foi bem legal deus não desse tanto fez
com que eu tenho eu sei que tem gente
que não é fã confesso admirador que acho
machos vídeo tal está sempre aqui mais
cara só de você tá me ajudam para você
está complicando gostei um vídeo isso me
ajuda e mais que isso é o meu trabalho
tá aí vai pegar todo o dinheiro arrecado
lá e aí vai fazer e vai mandar fazer os
ovos de páscoa a gente vai entregar no
final você fazia mas não deu tempo e no
encontro de fancaria boto meu facebook
boto meu estado no banco no twitter você
não consegue nada se você não assistiu
vica foi mal tá vendo isso aqui é bom
nisso e no facebook é bom seguir no
instagram é bom esse gratuito para não
perder essas coisas agora só no próximo
sábado deus lá quando é mais sério muito
obrigada também compareceu eu vou filmar
também a gente entregando a galera eu
quero as pessoas falam em você tem
fechado o cara tem muito cara muito
fechado mas graças a deus a maioria
absurda é de funk gosta que tem uma
pessoa que fica assim na tap e da tap a
tap gente vocês gente ela esquece o
passado é um número
a pessoa quando é que uma pessoa que tem
850 mil inscritos vai passar uma tampa
pessoa meu deus que eu sei se eu sem
passar meu salário fica a desgraça que
fique de gente falam falam falam um pão
imagina se eu passasse a ter também que
faço eu tenho um cento e eu sempre
tantos vídeos no canal eu faço mais de
100 vídeo que a pessoa gosta do vídeo
que eu falo do vídeo que eu falo uma
coisa que a minha opinião é diferente da
dela ela falar a meu respeito que gosta
de respeito em gente como eu fizer um
vídeo que você não concordar em sair o
dislike para você dar mas continuar
assistindo a assistir os outros na
última semana pode ser que venham com o
senhor como é que as pessoas assistissem
vídeos meus ela sabe como eu sou ela
sabe a minha característica ela sabe o
jeito que eu sou do jeito que eu bem sei
que eu não falo uma coisa diferente a
pessoa do nada o meu de 6 tipos e chega
para sua mãe na fatura que você gosta de
você gosta de você gosta muito do que
pra jantar hoje só tem um gol meu deus
mães era perdendo o respeito não tem
nexo que não tem nexo olha você que me
apavora você minha mãe não dizer pra
você pra você gostar de tudo que eu boto
você falar tudo que eu quero você
concordar com tudo o que eu digo não é
muito obrigada muito obrigada a todos os
tempos e da prova
cada um fala até em rádio am
a um cada barra no sábado
a ferramenta
e haverá churrasco o relacionamento não
sei que é o amor
[Música]
a entrada
oi tudo bem
foi uma busca provocar confusão você
roubar não é mesmo
valeu a música baixada volta de tv oi
tudo bem
então queria agradecer a toda galera que
veio aqui hoje
o show beneficente para ajudar o praia
completamente
e obrigado a ir em jogada que ele
nós vamos cantar a música sucesso do
brasil na rádio me falar que foi embora
olha olha a hora enquanto roda de baixa
[Música]
ainda de acordo
sei que é uma parte oi foi o gordinho
roberta olha aí como é amigo
a menina não tem ainda o apoio da
legenda à mostrada pela televisão
foi campeã foi há exatamente um ano o
cabelo puxado que não tiveram um você é
fã do canal se você é fã dos filhos e
gosta de tudo isso você quer com dilma
na sua cidade e fazer o encontro que
você comece aqui embaixo de qual cidade
e conquistar você é lógico você daquele
porque me ajuda muito valeu todo mundo é
fã e à noite
[Música]